Let's go back to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3 0
47 50 and see what is on people's minds.
Starting with our caller from the 2 4 0 area
code.
Who's calling today from 2 4 0.
Where are you calling from?
Thank you, Jason.
David, this is Rob.
I'm calling from Maryland.
Hey, Rob, what's up?
So I have I've always worked at small businesses,
I've always resisted going to big corporate
places for work because I know that I would
I would suffer it would be spirit crushing.
I prefer places where rather than there being
a very established culture, the place has
a malleable personality that I can actually
come in and contribute to, OK?
And big because I work for those types of
places.
I'm unemployed right now and and it's looking
less and less likely that those types of places
are going to come back after the dust settles
because, you know, they they typically have
much lower margins that they're running on,
that if they miss a month of profit, they
they can't keep up.
And so now I'm very reluctantly applying to,
you know, the Safeways and the c_v_s_ is and
the Burger Kings of the world, because that's
all that's going to be left after this.
And we're also kind of creating an entire
generation of, you know, the young people
right now who are seeing that they really
only have three kind of options as far as
career paths.
If they want their careers to be pandemic
proof, they can either go into public service
like government healthcare or education.
They can go into they can go work for
massive fast food chain or at a grocery store,
or they can get one of those corporate jobs
where they can work from home.
And those are diminishing.
Lee, rare.
I mean, those are the jobs of our parents
generation, not ours.
And so we are going to do it for for a long
time, have this shift.
I think that that crushes the dreams of a
lot of people who may have been better in
nonessential fields such as cosmetology or
the arts or culinary or, you know, being in
a research field of academia where you have
to actually go somewhere to study something.
And I want to know just if you had any ideas
about how.
How we could incentivize where it or if this
is even a good thing, like should unnecessary
jobs just.
Disappear.
And if not, how?
How do we incentivize people to still
follow their dreams?
So there's a lot there, Rob.
And so, first of all, I don't know that I
agree with you about the jobs that are pandemic
proof.
I mean, we just learned this week about the
nearly 5 percent GDP reduction in the first
quarter.
And half of that GDP reduction was in health
care, which is counterintuitive because with
so many coronavirus patients, what how could
that be?
It's because almost all non-emergency health
care has been shut down.
And it certainly has not been pandemic proof
for people who work in dermatology offices
and the like.
So I don't totally agree with the premise.
But what I would tell you is just because
a job is not essential in a pandemic doesn't
mean it's not an essential job.
So as an example, transportation is essential
to ninety nine point nine nine percent of
human existence.
We're in a pandemic
shut down where people aren't traveling.
So everything from from cab drivers to airline
pilots are suffering right now.
But I would not want to disincentivize people
from working in those fields because they're
so important.
Ninety nine point nine, nine percent of the
time.
What we need to do is we need to be Morse
take be more proactive.
As I spoke about on the Wednesday show this
week about softening the blow to a lot of
these industries, and by that I mean to the
workers not did like the hedge fund people
that are speculating in these businesses.
We need to have an economic system that's
more proactively protecting them.
But the last thing I would say is, hey, during
however long this says if it's two months,
if it's nine, whatever it is to say there
were jobs that weren't really useful during
that time.
These are jobs that are absolutely necessary
to to society, ninety nine point nine nine
percent of the time.
And I would not suggest people abandon them.
We just need to be better prepared to deal
with situations like this.
My friend, I'm going to let you go because
I have so many people that that want to get
on.
But it's an important question and I'm glad
that you asked it.